الثامن عشره من ايار مايو 2002 و20 تقدمت
السويد وفنلندا بطلب الانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي لتتخلي بذلك هل سنك
وستوكهولم عن الحياه العسكريه التي
تلتزمان به منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
مساءا قد يتحول الى تاريخ المفصلي ان
انتهى وفقا ما تريدانه اثرت حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا مخاوفهما وهما من دول الجوار
الروسي
ترى السويد وفنلندا ان عضويتهما في النيتو
ستشكل ضمانه لهما في وجه اي تهديدات روسيه
مستقبلا
ولحلف الناتو سيزيد انضمام الدولتين من
توسعه الجيو سياسي للدفاع عن دول البلطيق
التي يعتبرها الحلف بمثابه خاصرته الضعيفه
وسيصبح للحلف حدود اكثر قربا مع روسيا
ويتحول الى لاعب الرئيسي في الصراع معها
على النفوذ والموارد لكن الطموح قد يكون
ابعد منال على المدى المنثور في امتناع
تركيا يقف عائقا امام انضمام السويد
وفنلندا وتوسعه الناتو التي تحتاج الى
موافقه جميع اعضاء الحلف فانقر لن تقبل
الا بشروط تتعلق بانها القومي
تسليم من تصنفهم تركيا ارهابيين كما تطالب
بمنع عمل احزاب وجماعات
في جوها على لائحه الارهاب وعلى راسها حزب
العمال الكردستاني
في اللذه من جهتها تقول انها اوفت بما
عليها فيما يتعلق بمطالب تركيا
وتؤكد السويد انها قامت بما يلزم هي
الاخرى وعلى انقر البدء بالتصديق على
عضويتها
وبين البحث عن توسيع دائره النفوذ ومن يرى
الامن القوميه اولويه لا تنازل عنها يبقى
مصير توسع الحلف من عدمه في دائره الترقب
على الاقل